We're continuing our tour through truly incompetent
new Trumpy members of the House.
And Congresswoman Lauren Bobert is at the
top of the list, along with Marjorie Taylor
Green and Madison Cawthorn.
And as you may or may not know, Lauren Bobert
demands to be armed on the House floor.
She recently set off the metal detectors at
the House of Representatives.
This is a this is a wacky, wacky person.
She tweeted something which exposed her complete
lack of knowledge about the minimum wage and
economics.
She said, quote, I got my start working at
McDonald's.
That job doesn't exist.
If the minimum wage is raised to fifteen dollars
per hour, small business would be crushed
by this arbitrary mandate and big business
would simply automate away jobs.
Not everything that sounds good is actually
good in practice.
It is stunning how many bad arguments she
was able to squeeze into that one tweet.
First of all, she claims jobs at McDonalds
don't exist if you raise the minimum wage
to fifteen dollars per hour.
Minimum wage in Washington, D.C. is fifteen
dollars per hour.
McDonald's exist debunked number two.
She says that it's arbitrary to make the minimum
wage fifteen dollars an hour.
This is an argument we often hear from people
who come in and say, listen, if you're just
picking a number and more money for people
is good, why stop at fifteen dollars an hour,
make the minimum wage one hundred dollars
an hour, make it a thousand dollars an hour.
And of course, they are wrong that it is arbitrary,
a one hundred or a thousand dollar an hour
minimum wage is not defensible on the basis
of cost of living.
On the basis of work and productivity generated
by employees in typical minimum wage jobs,
it's not an equilibrium wage in the market.
So they want to say, oh, it's our 15 bucks.
It could be 12, it could be 100.
Make it a thousand.
Why not?
No, no, no.
There's nothing arbitrary about it.
And fifteen is probably a hair too low in
some places due to cost of living and in in
some other places, you could argue there are
really low cost of living places where maybe
you could argue fifteen is too high relative
to cost of living and revenue at small businesses.
But the idea that it's arbitrary is just completely
wrong.
And what what you have to understand, what
is she missing here?
And she's missing a lot.
Remember that labor is only one input at a
place like McDonalds.
And we've studied how meaningful wage increases
at places like McDonalds would have a very
small impact on the total cost, not the price.
The cost of a Big Mac and clueless people
have scammed their way into positions of power
by attaching themselves to the Trump scam
train, and Republican voters fell for it.
And now you have people like Lauren Bobert
who don't know anything in positions of power.
You also have to remember that when you increase
the minimum wage, you're creating demand side
stimulus, even though it might cost McDonald's
a little more to make the Big Mac because
of the increased minimum wage way more people
now have money to go buy more Big Macs.
That's the demand side stimulus component.
She also mentions they would automate jobs.
McDonald's has already been doing that for
a very long time, both in areas where there
is a 15 dollar minimum wage, a 14 dollar minimum
wage, a 13 dollar minimum wage and a seven
dollar minimum wage.
They've already been automating these touch
screen ordering machines at based delivery
and collection or, you know, all this different
stuff.
And so, of course, it's a total misunderstanding
by Lauren Bobert.
I don't think anyone's shocked that she doesn't
know a damn thing about economics, but the
reality is that we're only going to get more
of this if at some point the Republican Party
doesn't say we have to this has to stop even
people like, you know, OK, I would disagree
with Mitt Romney on policy, but he has a better
understanding of at least what the terms of
the debate are and how it should be discussed.
We would come to different conclusions.
He would have some bad ideas, I'm sure, about
supply side economics as an example.
But this is just a cartoonish farce.
People like Lauren Bobert.
And if the Republican Party learned anything
from the Trump fiasco, it would be to make
sure that in the 20 22 election, all of these
nuts lose that.
And I don't know that Republicans have actually
learned that.
Let me know if you think they have will be
back right after this.
The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.